nous débutons donc ce journal avec la
primaire de la gauche la primaire de la
belle alliance
les urnes ont livré le verdict du
premier tour
bonsoir wilfried bonsoir semaine
effectivement après cette campagne
express qui a été organisé les électeurs
ont tranché pour le second tour l'ancien
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire affronte l'ancien premier
ministre et deux chiffres à vous montrer
pour débuter il concerne la
participation sur le plan national tout
d'abord un peu plus d'un million six
cent mille électeurs se sont déplacés et
c'est beaucoup moins que les 2 millions
à 700 milles de la primaire et encore
moins que les 4 millions 300 mille du
premier tour de la primaire de la droite
dans le département à la participation
ne parvient pas à dépasser à les
quarante mille votants soit seulement 4
% du corps électoral yvelinois à la
droite avait de son côté atteint les 160
mille votants
au delà de la participation quels sont
les enseignements de ce premier tour
dans les airs et bien le premier
enseignement c'est que benoît hamon
réalise un score encore meilleur que
celui qu'ils réalisent au niveau
national l'ancien conseiller municipal
de trappes l'ancien élu à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines actuelle est député de la 11e
circonscription arrive en tête avec un
peu plus de 38 % loin devant manuel
valls à peine au dessus des 30 % on va
voir en comparaison est les résultats au
niveau national
à noter que ces résultats ne sont encore
que partiel la haute autorité n'a pas
terminé de valider l'ensemble être des
bulletins mais cela n'aura eu que très
peu d'incidence sur les chiffres au
final on revoit ses résultats avant de
détailler un peu plus ces chiffres dans
les yvelines et de s'arrêter justement
sur cette 11e circonscription que
détient actuellement benoît hamon
quelles sont les réactions ce matin eh
bien on va écouter tout d'abord la
réaction de sang green grand gang c'est
la responsable départementale du parti
socialiste
et c'est aussi un soutien de benoît
hamon quarante mille personnes qui se
déplacent à dimanche pour voter pour la
gauche dans les yvelines ces parias et
et puis aucun aucun problème de en
termes d'organisation est évidemment une
autre satisfaction qui est que dans un
monde largement en tête
j'ai quelqu'un qui humainement c'est de
la politique différemment donc quand il
accompagne le dit mais il n'est pas dans
des attaques personnelles ou des
préjugés et donc
j'espère que là du côté de l'équipe de
manuel valls on sera plus sur le fond
parce que autrement ça risque d'être
très intéressant en quoi il n'y a jamais
eu une seule gauche majoritaire tout
seul dans le pays donc et c'est vrai que
la droite aussi il faut faire des pas en
avant pour construire en commun
donc il ya là on me demande de choisir
effectivement deux d'entre deux projets
et après la gauche pourra se positionner
on va écouter d'autres réactions à
présent les réactions des soutiens aux
autres candidats dans le département de
la sénatrice catherine tasca au
conseiller régional eddie ait on peut
pas se contenter de ça surtout ne peut
pas vraiment se contenter de la
participation donc je pense que la
bataille à mener pendant cette semaine
pour convaincre et pour convaincre
d'appuyer manuel valls plutôt que benoît
hamon c'est d'amener beaucoup plus de
gens à voter
je pense que le score d'hier soir est
quand même limite même si ça fait
explique par plein de circonstance en
fait l'enjeu dans cette deuxième semaine
c'est d'offrir un choix qui soit un
choix clair pour l'avenir et pour
l'ensemble des électeurs de gauche
un choix entre une gauche qui est
imaginative il faut bien le reconnaître
mais fort peu réaliste et qui donne peu
de chances à son projet de voir vraiment
le jour et une gauche plus pragmatique
de mon point de vue beaucoup plus
sérieuse et qui donne des chances
réelles à la gauche de figurer en bonne
place dans la compétition feature qui
sera le moment de vérité
franchement oui c'est une déception
c'est quand on soutient un candidat et
personnellement moi je le soutiens
depuis pas mal d'années depuis 2002
lorsqu'il a commencé à créer le nps à
réfléchir sur la 6ème république
donc ça fait quand même un certain bon
bout de temps arnaud montebourg a eu
cette spontanéité d'appeler à voter pour
amont tout de suite
et ce qui est logique il n'y a pas de
surprise de ce côté là et je pense que
99,9 pour cent des soutiens d'arnaud
montebourg iront soutenir benoît hamon
ce sans vraiment se forcer parce que ce
ne sera pas difficile et en espérant la
victoire au bout je note que au niveau
national avec une participation en
baisse d'un million par rapport à 2011
sylvia pinel double le score de 2-2 2011
donc c'est une vraie progression pour
cette candidate
je rappelle que c'était la seule femme
de la primaire à la moins de 40 ans moi
j'étais assez fier que le prg 1 présente
sa candidature elle a souhaité axer sa
campagne sur l'expression d'un programme
de centre gauche
la porte est un certain nombre de
valeurs sur les questions sociétales un
programme ambitieux pour le soutien à
l'artisanat aux commerces aux tpe et aux
pme
donc maintenant nous allons continuer ce
travail
le deuxième tour ce sera dès ce dimanche
il y aura donc deux gauches en
compétition de gauche a priori
irréconciliables la suite de la campagne
qui s'annonce donc beaucoup plus
virulente et on le verra si ça se
confirme ou non lors du dernier débat le
débat de l'entre-deux-tours ce sera
mercredi
voilà pour l'instant ce qu'en pense
benoît hamon justement ce clivage si le
clivage quand on a retrouvé pendant cinq
ans pendant lesquels je trouve
différents parce que l'arrêté du clivage
pendant les cinq dernières années
portait plus sur à désaccords que nous
pouvions avoir sur les orientations de
politique économique le fait que mes
propositions soient délibérément
retourner vers le futur qui aujourd'hui
va créer de l'adhésion vis-à-vis de mon
projet mais aussi très delà de la
surprise un peu de
voilà deux des reproches aussi la parade
mais de mes rivaux qui comprennent pas
forcément le sens des propositions que
je formule en tout cas on partage pas
l'orientation voilà pour terminer deux
puisque vous parlez de benoît hamon
quel est le bilan de sa campagne dans
les yvelines alors qu'il remporte ou non
à cette primaire et quel que soit le
verdict de la présidentielle en mai
benoît à moi en tout cas eu le soutien
des militants du ps
en tout cas de ceux qui sont déplacés
aux urnes voici tout d'abord le résultat
dans sa circonscription la 11e
circonscription plus de 55% des
suffrages exprimés manuel valls n est qu
à 22 2% et puis si l'on regarde plus en
détail les résultats encore sur cette
11e circonscription sur la commune de
trappes ou benoît hamon assiégé la ville
où il était élu conseiller municipal il
atteint les 73 %
attention néanmoins le nombre des
électeurs ce n'est pas énorme
on parle d'environ 765 personnes et on
écoute
thomas hardy qui est responsable du
bureau de vote on peut parler d'un effet
benoît hamon on a une centaine de
bulletins en plus et on verra bien mais
voilà au niveau national mais en tout
cas au niveau local on sent bien qu'il
ya une impulsion une dynamique
benoît hamon et c'est ce qui a fait
certainement aussi la différence avec
2011 avec le taux de participation
voilà pour les militants du ps qu'en
pense la population micro trottoir à
présent réalisée dans les rues de
trappes ce matin de l'avantagé d'avoir
quelques idées nouvelles par rapport à
certains je sais pas parce que le jet
ministre dans le précédent le
gouvernement l'aude
or je sais pas ce qu'il peut apporter
j'ai pas l'opinion là tu sais pour
concernés par les socialistes
et si nous on fait pour la loi travail
c'est mort moi j'ai voté pour lui donc
y'a pas de soucis même si je pas parti
socialiste j'en avais marre de monsieur
valls voilà ouais je suis fatigué de la
politique parce qu'ils racontent que des
voix là je ne suis pas contre monsieur
hamon en tant qu'ouvrier
éducation ouvrière jeffrey provôté
ailleurs comme le nombre de votants mon
avis est quand même pas très
significatif pour ça que ça ne m'inspire
pas plus que ce à quoi on sent qu'il y
aura du changement et on ne sait pas on
verra on espère une dernière réaction
pour conclure c'est celle du maire
d'elancourt le maire les républicains il
est candidat à d'ores et déjà dans cette
11e circonscription celle de benoît
hamon est d'ailleurs jean-michel
fourgous était député de cette 11e
circonscription jusqu'en 2012
voilà ce qu'il pense du candidat benoît
hamon est ce résultat monsieur hamon
qu'est-ce qui l'a vendu il a perdu de la
solidarité il a pas vendu de la
répartition il a pas entendu des génomes
il a vendu une image donc de faire
croire aux gens que ça va être possible
avec monsieur ça
ce genre de technique je le condamne le
plus fermement que ce soit monsieur
hamon ou un autre sens monsieur hamon a
priori vous savez il a il a de fortes
chances de devenir de de gagner
certaines au second tour je suis triste
de voir que il ya encore quinze pour
cent des français qui croient qu'un pays
qui à 81 milliard déficit de 1200
milliards de dette
il peut se permettre de délire un gars
qui dit vous inquiétez pas je vous
trouverez 300 milles ça ça c'est grave
c'est sale c'est ça le problème qui est
grave
fried et on revoit le résultat de cette
primaire dans les yvelines
benoît hamon en tête avec 38% des
suffrages manuel valls dépasse tout
juste les 30%